the Joe Rogan experience I don't know if
you saw the video of that kid that was
jogging Ahmad yes I mean what is going
on like I'm not surprised I can say I'm
not surprised like something when Rick
its Arista the guy in the back of the
pickup truck with a shotgun the other
guy jumps out and he's trying to grab
the shotgun from them they shoot him
like what my thing is how do we have
laws that say that you could chase
somebody with guns and here's the thing
if you notice in the video the truck is
in front of them so they chase them got
in front of them the guy that's running
behind him it's almost like like a mod
was trapped a guy chasing you with a
camera the truck was already pulled up
so it was certainly trapped I mean
there's chased him down and it's
vigilantism even look even if he did
something me I don't even know if he did
anything no he said he was just right
but no there's actually photograph
there's videos of him walking into a
house being built like it's just water
inside right he looked at it what I told
my wife when I would do that [ __ ] when I
was a kid me too I was telling my wife
we just did that the other day they're
building a house and we just oh let's
see where this is and and Denny jogs on
didn't steal anything didn't have
anything just jogging now how do we come
to a point in our country where two men
can chase him down with guns and then
get in a fight with them and then say it
was self-defense
well I think Georgia has some crazy laws
citizens of a citizen's arrest and also
they have ties to law enforcement yes
the father was with the DEA and then the
prosecutor the local prosecutor wrote
this letter that said basically he
burglarized the kid Ahmad burglarized
something which he didn't and they had
every right to pull him over and when he
didn't stop they got in a fight and so
they had every right to kill him so now
the the government came in like the big
dogs came in and then they arrested two
people in two days and it was just like
uh we don't think so and here's the
thing social media I did it did took the
outrage of people finding out about the
case but when
found out that it happened months ago Oh
to 23 February 20 I mean Jerry February
23rd months these guys were out and they
knew that they had shot him and then he
really had the video here's it's really
crazy the video was released by their
own lawyer you know why because they
thought it showed that the guy tried to
take the gun away look this is gonna
free you what I'm doing the southern
accident released the video and then
everyone's gonna know that dude released
the video and this is what I heard he
released that it helped he helped him
because the guy didn't stop when they
tried to pull him over [ __ ] imagine
being a 25 year old black man and two
white guys in the back of a pickup truck
with shotguns pull over and there's no
one else around
holy what was the kid's supposed to do
just stop and talk to two men with guns
exactly it's it's and then and then I
was listening to reports like before
this video even came out here's what's
crazy the police had the video at the
beginning and they still dismissed it
they had this at the beginning they
didn't release it the lawyer released it
like you said so they had it at the
beginning that the lawyer thought that
that was gonna help his clients you know
what I think and I don't know much about
the person that shot it but if I'm
guessing everybody's done okay
I think he shot the video whoever this
guy was it's almost like a hero video
look at this we caught a guy that
burglarized like they felt like oh this
and then the guns start going off yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah
maybe in Ben vigilantism is scary man
because people just decide that they're
right and they decide that this is the
this is the person and no due process no
try on your plate with shotguns drawn
like cops don't even do that man they
turned the lights on first they pull you
over they start talking to you they'll
pull the gun out right away when you
just jog in well some cops do that too
so I but I do think I mean it's deep
south I mean a warm territory it's it's
it's races I think racism led it to you
know well it's very likely yeah it's
very
very least it has to be considered as of
one of the main components of this
innovation absolutely I just feel that
you know anytime you bring up race
you'll have the audience that goes oh
you got to bring up race but this was a
black guy that got shot by two white
guys with shotguns let's take away race
let's say the two guys shot a white guy
that was jogging it's still wrong yeah
you know it's still wrong if even if you
take the potential racism out take it
out you got a 25 year old just kid who's
out jogging yeah those guys pull out
with shotguns and tell them to you know
hey we want to talk to you like [ __ ]
well you've heard this some people don't
even think racism is real like oh
there's no racism in America
I mean I've races people doesn't believe
it's like saying sexism isn't real but
they don't because it is you know like
you said something at The Comedy Store
and it may have been done 118 specials
where you were talking about something
and you said that's only four people ago
yeah the United States 1776 yeah that's
only four people go three people go
three people effect so if you think
about that right three people go people
own people own people so you were racist
and then your kids were racist yeah my
dad is that third level being black had
to go through racism so words still in
it can't go away that fast it takes a
long time to go away when you've got the
roots of it that's still deeply embedded
in these cities right like yeah this is
like Baltimore Georgia's red lines where
you weren't even allowed to sell a home
to someone who was black in certain
districts yeah was it legal I mean my
dad has a PhD in nuclear physics and hat
went to a college where he couldn't even
need at restaurants on campus and where
was that he went to Oklahoma State at
certain restaurants on campus what year
is this well he's 75 so sixties so
during the civil rights all the riots
and he'd let my dad was in marches to
try to get the local restaurant to let
him in so it's a thing where when people
go
racism is in tibet my dad is only 75
right right and he went through it
during his life during his lifetime
right now so and this is when and this
is when my dad was telling me when he
was growing up this is how crazy my dad
said he didn't even know he was poor
growing up because they never left the
area they couldn't go anywhere he never
knew they were poor he never saw white
people because they weren't allowed to
go anywhere anyway so he never knew they
were in poverty
[Applause]